to joe biden other human beings only
exist the extent they can be used for
partisan ends so it shouldn't surprise
you that on friday he used the story of
a ten-year-old rape victim to push for
more abortion
according to joe biden the laws in ohio
forced a ten-year-old rape victim to
flee to indiana to get that abortion
now the white house never vetted the
facts of that story it's the president
united states saying things that no one
checked but the facts didn't make any
sense on monday for example the attorney
general of ohio said there would not be
a reason for this child to flee to ohio
in the first place watch
ohio's heartbeat law has a medical
emergency exception
it broader than just the life of the
mother
she this young girl if she exists and if
this horrible thing actually happened to
her breaks my heart to think about it
she did not have to leave ohio to find
treatment the obvious headline here was
not about abortion it was about the
crime committed against a child who
raped a ten-year-old that was our first
question nobody seemed interested at all
in learning who this person was
and maybe there was a reason for that in
fact there was another moral to this
story apparently the rapist was an
illegal alien
the columbus dispatch is reporting
tonight that a 27 year old called
gershon fuentes has confessed to raping
the 10 year old child on multiple
occasions victor davis hanson is a
senior fellow at the hoover institution
and we're happy to have him joining us
tonight professor thanks so much
for coming on so what do you take from
this story
well it's a tragic story tucker but it
gets more mysterious
every day because apparently
this terrible horrendous act was
reported on the 22nd or near abouts in
june
and here we are on july 13th 14th and
we're only now
learning about who did this in other
words this perpetrator apparently was
not charged or arraigned and yet people
knew that he had
coerced a young at maybe at the time a
nine-year-old to be pregnant and so the
question is why now
at this belated date are we learning who
he was and maybe i mean a naive might
say well it was because people had
questioned the veracity of the story and
people for whatever nebulous reasons
didn't want to reveal his identity until
revealing his identity was the only
mechanism for substantiating the story
in the first place but in that time
it seems like a person who had a
proclivity to have you know coercive sex
with minors was still out there and we
don't know what he was doing he should
have been as soon as they reported the
act he should have been arraigned
immediately and then the next thing was
the attorney general mentioned the
heartbeat law at six weeks
but the abortionists who became the
spokesman for the story said well
the abortion was committed uh was um
done six weeks and three days i mean
can't you why was it so close to that
day it was almost as if if you knew
about this act you had a a a
method inside ohio if you believe that
that was a proper course it would have
been legal within six weeks rather than
to go
over to indiana and then be told well it
was six weeks and three days it doesn't
the whole all of these details
they reek of uh a political
weaponization of the case which is
tragic because we have a nine-year-old i
guess at the time of the act she was
nine
and she's being used for political
purposes which is terrible and then we
have this perpetrator and now we learn
that he is here illegally from guatemala
and he's residing illegally and no one
has uh he was the actor was reported and
for two almost three weeks
he hasn't been charged so
we don't we're gonna have to wait for
more details but it's it's mysterious
it's terrible what's going on
so it sounds like in this case as in
pretty much every case we've reported on
for the past five years the first
version was a lie
everything is partisan propaganda and
kind of believe nothing at first maybe
that's the takeaway
it reminds me a lot of the whipping
story that joe biden also promulgated
about border patrol's whipping people
and we found out only later
that
it wasn't true at all and then there
were desperate efforts to bring in more
evidence to sort of incriminate them to
save the reputation of the president so
i think what's happened is that this
fellow was finally charged when they
needed some substantiation of this story
but they didn't seem
they seemed reluctant to charge him
quicker and more almost immediately
because they felt the story would be
believable and be useful on its own
merits and then when people questioned
it and wanted details only then did they
start releasing the details which caused
only more mystery but the whole thing is
is
i think it's it's terrible because it
shows you that people are using a 10
year old and and protecting in some
cases and illegal aiding if that
happened to be true that they
deliberately delayed arraigning him
until they needed evidence to
substantiate this useful story it's it's
it's terrible
they don't care about people they care
about power vic james hanson appreciate
you coming outside thank you
thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight